from animated favorites to Holiday
Classics these movies are beloved
nowadays but you wouldn't be able to
tell if you just saw how much money they
made in theaters the bizarrely Charming
Willy Wonka and the Chocolate Factory
wasn't a hit when it came out in 1971.
although it's considered a classic Now
it only earned about 4 million dollars
upon its release which wasn't great
considering its 3 million dollar budget
this may have happened because it was
marketed as a family-friendly film even
though it had no shortage of moments
that could be considered scary for
children
do something
hell Police Murder Roald Dahl the author
of the 1964 book the film was based on
was outspoken about his dislike of the
film adaptation he didn't like the songs
the numerous changes to the plot or how
the focus seemed to be on Willy Wonka
rather than Charlie Bucket Willy Wonka
and the Chocolate Factory became much
more popular after its re-release in
1996 and availability on home video it's
now considered one of Gene Wilder's most
iconic roles and that's saying a lot
considering he has no shortage of
Unforgettable performances the film's
popularity led to the 2005 remake
Charlie and the Chocolate Factory
starring Johnny Depp and the prequel
Wonka starring Timothy chalamet which is
set for release in December 2023. it may
be the movie with the longest ever
theatrical run but The Rocky Horror
Picture Show most definitely bombed
during its initial release he even
though it was based on a popular stage
musical the film adaptation only earned
21 245 dollars in its opening weekend
disappointed with the premier 20th
Century Fox pulled the movie from
several other locations around the
country for most films that would have
been the end of the story but one
advertising executive had a brilliant
idea start showing The Rocky Horror
Picture Show at one of the popular
midnight shows at the Waverly theater in
New York City when they did it proved an
instant hit after several months of late
night showings with a party-like
atmosphere one of waverly's Rocky Horror
regulars from mild Manor kindergarten
teacher Louis Faris started to shout
improvised lines back at the screen the
midnight showing soon spread to other
theaters around the country along with
the habit of shouted audience callbacks
eventually dedicated fans began to form
shadowcast performance troops acting out
the film and costume on stage as the
movie plays on the big screen behind
them within a year Rocky Horror went
from a box office bomb to a cult
sensation that's still going strong more
than 40 years later it's hard to believe
that the Wizard of Oz one of the most
beloved and influential films of all
time bombed at the box office but it's
true when the 1939 classic was released
it made a mere three million dollars
against a production and distribution
budget of over 4 million dollars people
just weren't rushing to the theaters to
see a farm girl explore an alternate
world with a lion a scarecrow and a tin
man on the bright side it mostly earned
positive reviews and went on to win two
Academy Awards one for best original
song and the other for best original
score
preachers think yourselves lucky that
I'm giving you audience tomorrow instead
of 20 years from now the film started
making profits after it was re-released
in 1949 thanks in part to Judy Garland's
elevated startup it earned even more
money after it was re-released again in
1955. aired on TV beginning in 1956 and
came out on Home Video in 1980. nowadays
it's an undeniable classic and has made
around 25.6 million dollars overall not
bad considering its original budget the
film has also inspired multiple remakes
and spin-offs including the 2013 film Oz
the Great and Powerful and the
long-running Broadway musical Wicked
many of us grew up watching Hocus Pocus
every Halloween so it might come as a
surprise that the cult classic wasn't an
instant hit upon its 1993 release the
film grossed about 45 million dollars so
it managed to recoup its 28 million
dollar budget but not by much when
compared to Disney's other holiday films
for instance Disney had released the
Santa Claus the following year which
made almost 200 million dollars on a 22
million dollar budget Hocus Pocus should
have been released around Halloween but
it was released in July instead a
decision that essentially set it up to
fail Disney had thought a summer release
would be better for the movie as kids
would be out of school from a practical
standpoint a July release would mean
that it wouldn't compete with their
other spooky film set to come out that
year The Nightmare Before Christmas
while Tim Burton's holiday mashup had
nearly quadrupled its budget by the time
it left theaters Hocus Pocus wasn't so
lucky despite its underwhelming Premiere
Hocus Pocus eventually Put a Spell on
viewers it started airing on TV every
Halloween in the late 90s and it gained
even more fans after its 2002 DVD
release the sequel Hocus Pocus 2 came
out in 2022 starring the original Trio
of actors as the Sanderson sisters
Ridley Scott's sci-fi epic Blade Runner
left a huge impact on Cinema and is
considered nowadays to be a science
fiction Masterpiece despite its current
reputation though it only grossed about
26 million dollars in the summer of 1982
on a 28 million dollar budget to make
matters worse many people who saw the
movie didn't have great things to say
about it some viewers thought the pacing
was slow and others didn't like how Grim
the story was I've had people walk out
of me before but not when
I was being so Charming many
commercially successful films have
simple plots and tons of action but
Scott was more interested in making an
artistic film with thought-provoking
themes Blade Runner also had stiff
competition when it was released E.T the
Extraterrestrial Star Trek 2 Wrath of
Khan and Conan the Barbarian all came
out around the same time as time went on
Blade Runner gained a sizable following
and was recut multiple times ending up
with about 39.5 million dollars it its
popularity inspired the 2017 sequel
Blade Runner 2049 the 2021 animated
series Blade Runner Black Lotus and the
upcoming live action series Blade Runner
2099 Children of Men has powerful themes
about the resilience of the human spirit
that are just as relevant now as they
were when the film came out in 2006.
unfortunately Alfonso Caron's
Masterpiece wasn't able to recoup the
cost of its production earning around
70.5 million dollars on a 76 million
dollar budget one reason for this was
The film's Limited theatrical release
which meant many people couldn't see it
even if they wanted to on top of that
Universal Pictures didn't Market the
movie successfully they weren't sure
what demographic wanted to see a bleak
dystopian sci-fi movie devoid of flashy
laser guns and flying spaceships in
their promotional campaign reflected
their uncertainty on the plus side
Children of Men has since gotten the
recognition it deserves the film was met
with glowing reviews upon its release
and it has an impressive critic score of
92 percent on Rotten Tomatoes it won
multiple Awards as well including best
science fiction film at the Saturn
Awards and best cinematography at the
baftas
Fear and Loathing in Las Vegas is one of
those movies that people either love or
hate unfortunately for director Terry
Gilliam and the hundreds of people who
worked on the film most people hated it
when it came out in 1998. it earned a
mere 13.7 million dollars in theaters
failing to break even on its 18.5
million dollar budget the movie style of
Storytelling isn't for everyone it's
chaotic trippy and downright confusing
at times meant to mimic the altered
state of mind that the characters are in
due to their constant drug usage
regardless of the intent some audiences
find it more overwhelming than
entertaining Fear and Loathing in Las
Vegas gained a cult following after it
was released on DVD Johnny Depp who
starred as Raul Duke had since
skyrocketed in popularity after
portraying Captain Jack Sparrow in
2003's Pirates of the Caribbean and as
the Black Pearl sailed into movie
history Fear and Loathing followed in
its wake additionally movies using the
altered stream of Consciousness style
had become more mainstream in the past
years so it wasn't as jarring for
viewers anymore this allowed audiences
to admire the film for its Unique Style
and themes of self-indulgence
disillusionment and the constant search
for the American dream I mean the things
worth doing
we're doing right
this is the American dream in action
when Paul verhoven's Starship Troopers
came out in 1997 its marketing made it
seem as though it would be a goofy
science fiction Adventure rather than a
satire of the military-industrial
complex thanks in part to this bait and
switch poor Word of Mouth led to the
movie earning a mere 54.8 million
dollars during its domestic release
slightly over half of its 105 million
dollar budget Starship Troopers didn't
have a star-studded cast to draw
audiences in the lead actors were Casper
Van Dean and Denise Richards who weren't
big names at the time the film was also
quite different from the 1959 novel by
Robert Heinlein that it was based on
which definitely threw some people off
the book depicted military life in a
positive light and audiences may have
assumed the film would do the same
nothing could be further from the truth
what really put the nail in the coffin
though was the movie's release date it
came out the same year as the Lost World
Jurassic Park and a month before Titanic
so it had a tough time gaining notoriety
although Starship Troopers was vastly
misunderstood upon its release it
eventually gained popularity among a
niche audience it eventually went on to
reach a final gross of 121 million
dollars overall thanks to International
screenings the animated family film The
Iron Giant has gained an impressive
audience since its release in 1999 but
it was initially a huge commercial
failure Brad Bird's beloved tearjerker
only made about 31.3 million dollars
against a 50 million dollar budget due
to poor marketing for Warner Brothers
they had recently released the film
Quest for Camelot which had bombed at
the box office so they weren't willing
to spend a lot of money promoting
another animated movie as a result
hardly anyone seemed to notice when The
Iron Giant was finally released despite
all of that the movie was adored by
those who did go to see it bands and
critics alike praised the film for its
beautiful animation likable characters
and balance of funny and heart-wrenching
Moments by the time it was released on
DVD it had already established a
following but being available on home
video helped it reach an even wider
audience you're a good guy
like Superman
foreign
Treasure Planet was packed with
Adventure quirky characters and
beautifully animated scenes so it should
have been a box office hit but that
wasn't the case the film cost a whopping
140 million dollars to make and grossed
about 110 million dollars costing Disney
a pretty penny after its 2002 release
unfortunately this movie was doomed to
fail it was set for release around the
same time as Harry Potter and the
Chamber of Secrets the Santa Claus 2 and
Die Another Day Disney also didn't
Market the film very well and its target
audience was unclear despite being
promoted as a family film The Plot is a
bit too complicated for children the
main character is a moody teenager and
there are no princesses or musical
numbers to be found at the same time its
perceived status as a kids movie kept
the older crowd from flocking to
theaters to see it although Treasure
Planet garnered mixed reviews and tanked
at the box office people started
recognizing its unique charm after it
came out on DVD they came to love the
film's mature themes relatable
characters and stunning animation style
that mixes hand-drawn frames with CGI
countless films have faded Into
Obscurity over the years but Citizen
Kane has remained highly renowned for
decades it wasn't always so popular
though as it earned about 1.6 million
dollars against its 800 000 budget when
it came out in 1941. that made Orson
welles's Masterpiece not much of a
financial success despite the many
positive reviews it received for its
outstanding performances and
cinematography I did lose a million
dollars last year I expect to lose a
million dollars this year I expect to
lose a million dollars next year the
main reason for the disappointing
turnout was the controversy surrounding
the film prior to its release powerful
publishing Tycoon William Randolph
Hearst was offended by his similarity to
the movie's troubled main character
Charles Foster Kane so he did everything
he could to stop the film from being
released as a result it had a delayed
and limited rollout which severely
impacted its box office performance it
did however win best original screenplay
at the Academy Awards Citizen Kane
gained a lot more praise after it was
re-released in the 1950s and began
airing on TV as the years went on it
became are one of the best of the best
influencing countless other films and
earning its place in cinematic history
when it comes to Christmas movies It's a
Wonderful Life is a go-to for many
families year after year when the movie
came out in 1946 though it was such a
failure that it led to director Frank
Caprice production company shutting down
the future holiday classic originally
had a budget of about 2 million dollars
but multiple script rewrites and changes
to the crew nearly doubled the cost of
production it earned a measly 3.3
million dollars upon its 1946 release
and garnered mixed reviews It's a
Wonderful Life was released a few years
after World War II had ended which
contributed to its unimpressive box
office numbers American audiences were
not necessarily in the mood for a
supposedly inspirational holiday movie
that eventually has a happy ending but
also features more than a few shockingly
dark moments
also came out around the same time as
the best years of Our Lives which blew
it out of the water It's a Wonderful
Life didn't become popular until decades
later its copyright ended in 1974 so TV
channels started airing it every
Christmas because they didn't have to
pay any royalties for it people began
realizing how good of a film it truly is
and the rest is history